why did you
call it the free energy principle when i
first heard well i heard about it
quite a few times then i kept dismissing
it because i thought it was referring to
perpetual motion
or the extraction of energy from vacuum
fluctuations
right i understand that it has something
to do with free energy in the physics
term but
what led you to calling it the free
energy principle and have you had have
you heard of
other people have you heard of the case
of mistaken identity
from other people is it just me no no i
i've certainly come across that
but not so nicely articulated or gently
articulated
and so yeah for me in my world um the
free energy
was the um the most natural and obvious
uh thing
to call it because um the the kind of
free energy that we're dealing with or
when i say we
um people in either base in statistics
or laterally what would be known as
machine learning
would would
would always refer to this quantity this
variational free energy
as a computable objective function for
any
inference or estimation problem so
whether you're doing sort of
um classification with machine learning
and you're using restricted builds of a
machine
and you're using or let's make it more
current
so you're doing um you using high-end
deep learning using a variational auto
encoder to try and recognize
um some sequence of images then
the weights that you are optimizing with
in that deep learning setting in that
particular variation auto encoder
setting
um are optimized with respect to a
variation free energy
so this variation free energy plays a
central role and has done for
for more than half a century now
in optimization problems um
its origins are actually really really
quite interesting
um historically again this is not really
my field but from what i gather
there are two ways that the free energy
sort of
came into play the the the american
route
and this starts with richard feynman as
with most things
um so he had the problem of
basically um wanting to
[Music]
you know express simply
um evaluate the probability distribution
over all the paths a an electron say
could could could take
and he realized that that was a you know
an intractable
um integration problem he could you
couldn't work out the sort of
the normalization constant to make sure
that probability distribution
summoned to one so he was faced with an
intractable
um effectively integration problem in
quantum electrodynamics
so he solved him by converting that
integration problem into an optimization
problem
and the way he did it was to introduce a
variation free energy
that was always greater than the
quantity that he wanted to minimize or
was less than
the quantity that he wanted to maximize
which in this instance is just
the marginal likelihood or the
likelihood distribution of various paths
say a small particle might take um so
that's where i learned about free energy
essentially a thyme and if i'm an free
energy
that was provided a bound approximation
to something that you actually wanted to
maximize or optimize
and in my world that that thing you want
to
maximize is the model evidence or the
marginal likelihood
because back to self-evidencing but also
the marginal likelihood
sort of indicating that this is a
central notion in in physics
in bayesian statistics as as well
and that quantity that variation free
energy um has been in play now for
for for for you know not quite a century
but certainly many many decades
um currently known as an um an elbow
elbow and evidence lower bound
so that evidence lower bound underwrites
you know all of high-end machine
learning um
and you know certain simply reduced
cases of it i
i would i would actually suggest
probably all of machine learning at some
point um refer to or can be uh
seen as a special case of this the other
route
um inherits more from the russian side
um and this is you know your notions of
algorithmic complexity underlying
universal computation
via common growth complexity and sort of
induction
um so the big drive there
is is again formulating
universal computation as basically
communicating or articulating or
encoding
some structure in the simplest way
possible
by introducing a bound
on the thing that you want to you want
to
optimize or minimize or extremize so you
can also
find the free energy
in the context of um sort of
um a more shallow nest
like uh take on on communication and
optimization
and david mckay sort of originally
um brought that perspective to the table
perspective
that was was um well understood by
people like uh wallace in uh
melbourne who themselves had
taken it from from the the russian
literature and so on
i think he was he was an american but
also uh
you know taking his algorithmic
complexity so it's a very long answer to
to actually say that the free energy
principle
or the principle of minimizing free
energy
has underwritten um universal
computation
uh practical approaches to quantum
electrodynamics
and machine learning since since the
1950s
so it was you know that's what the free
energy means it's not the
the energy is costless it's it's it's
just
uh borrows from the formalism
of the thermodynamic uh free energy
either gibbs or a helmholtz
free energy
you